d'abord la ministre a fait un choix pour
ses
enfants ce sont des choix individuels
personnels je le disais il faut les
respecter et je trouve que c'est bien et
je pense que tous nos compatriotes
d'ailleurs iront dans ce sens et et je
pense que ça fait partie de la vie
intime familiale que beaucoup d'ailleurs
qui sont indignes parfois le font pour
leurs propres enfants eux-mêmes et j'ai
pas rentré là-dedans moi je le respecte
et je l'ai dit moi j'ai étis dans les
deux écoles je relisais d'ailleurs un
texte de Jean jores qui avait eu à subir
en 1901 une polémique absolument
terrible parce qu'il avait fait faire la
communion à sa fille et il avait avec
beaucoup d'humilité dit je tranche pas
mieux qu'un autre ces débats qui sont
ceux de chaque citoyen individuel et
personnel ensuite la ministre a eu un
propos public qui a été maladroit elle
s'en est excusé elle a bien fait je vais
vous dire j'ai plutôt de l'indulgence
parce qu'il m'est arrivé d'avoir des
propos au tout début de mes
responsabilités politiques qui avaient
blessé tout particulièrement des femmes
euh dans une entreprise du Grand Ouest
et et quand on blesse surtout sans s'en
rendre compte on a raison de s'excuser
moi je pense que il y a pas d'écolees
qui tiennent si on n' pas tous nos
enseignants avec nous il faut un travail
remarquable et j'ai l'occasion de le
dire il travaille d'arrache-pied pour
préparer leurs cours corriger leurs
copies et devant les élèves continuer
d'innover et donc la ministre réussira à
sa tâche avec les enseignants après elle
a soulevé un sujet qui est un sujet
véritable votre collègue l'a rappelé et
ce sera une des priorités qu'elle aura
conduite à conduire dans le droitfil de
ce que le premier ministre avait encore
à faire il y a quelques
semaines